oh that's like the untold story of
feminism like the idea that oh feminism
was just women who
wanted to vote like that's that's like a
cartoon caricature like
that's not really like the true full
story like
the original feminists were the
colonizers
these european men who want to save you
know quote unquote save
muslim women as an excuse to control and
take over
and kill muslims so
for a muslim to be a feminist is like
the most ironic thing
and it's the most backwards and
contradictory thing
no two things could be more incompatible
[Music]
you know you could do this without
school you already know that you can
bring in money
now the question is can you bring home
some paychecks and show that to mommy
and daddy
can you prove it that you can do it
because at the end of the day
they still have this traditional eastern
philosophy that you need to go to school
we came here we sacrificed our life
for you to go to college so you can get
this degree and
make this money whereas bro i keep
preaching this
you don't need school if you don't need
school
if you're not trying to be a doctor
you're not trying to be a lawyer you're
not trying to be
some type of engineer i'm talking about
an actual practical engineer
right not like a programming uh you know
software engineer that can
that's you can do it from your laptop
bro now
these types of things go go to school
but you don't need one to be a software
engineer
can you be a software engineer through
school of course
can you be one without school of course
so why take the route that you might
have to
indulge in ribba in interest in student
loans
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to t3m
we are back
and we are better with our brother
daniel akikachu
assalamualaikum daniel
yeah so tell me man what's changed in
the last two days since we spoke
nothing much just busy with a lot of
stuff but
everything's good
all right so today i want to i want to
go right in
we see we live in a society where we got
phenotypic
men right undeniably phenotypic men
with pronouns in their bible as if you
know somebody needed clarification we
got
we got people we got the metoo movement
we got feminism
and then we got islam which is the
antithesis
but it's not overtly so to the point
where we got a lot of muslim sisters
that
claim to be feminists or claim to be
salafi
feminists or hijabis and to me it seems
like a contradiction so
i want you to get into this man where
where did this whole feminism thing
began
was it truly for equality does it mean
that islam doesn't have equality for men
and women
are they not equal
yeah sure
feminism started as a weapon
against non-white people
that's pretty much the origins of
feminism as
a attack in the colonial project
so you had europeans enlightened
europeans who are part of this liberal
secular project
trying to colonize the rest of the world
and this is known as the
what was known as the white man's burden
and it was
racialized it was this idea that the
white
european man uh is
intellectually superior and has a higher
iq
and the european mind is scientific
and is best able to determine the right
way to live
as we talked about in the in the
previous discussion on liberalism
and so they want to export this this was
their burden to
civilize the rest of humanity and bring
them into the light of reason
and part of this project was to
criticize
family practices basically to look
at these other cultures and say look how
backwards they are
look how they treat their women okay
that was a big component of it and
it also generated a lot of justification
for the colonial project because it
tapped into this kind of
savior mindset like we need to go save
these women
from these evil men right and there's a
book
that is pretty well known it's called do
muslim women need saving
and it talks about the more modern
context in the run-up to the
invasion of iraq and afghanistan
in the past 20 years where a lot of the
justification for that was
these muslim women are being oppressed
by muslim men
these muslim women are being subjugated
in their homes they have to dress like
this with the hijab
and the cop they are not allowed to just
move around freely they can't go
and marry whoever they want they need
like a
so this is oppression and we need to
save those muslim women
and that generated a lot of support for
the war in some
segments of western society in america
and in europe
and but this is not something new it
didn't just start with the iraq war in
2003
or the invasion of afghanistan in 2001
it actually predates that to the
beginning of the colonial period
which was back at the end of the 18th
century this is so then what happened
though is that
that weapon that was being used against
muslims
and other like the chinese as well
certain aboriginals as well native
americans
the same arguments that they make
against muslims like oh
muslims abuse women because of polygamy
for example
or because of like inheritance
law and marriage law this is oppressive
those same practices to a certain extent
exist in for native many native american
tribes
existed for many kinds of traditional
cultures
so all of these arguments that they've
been using against muslims they were
also using as all of these different
non-european cultures and people in an
effort to colonize the entire
world but then what started happening
towards the end of the
19th century those arguments
now are being picked up by white
women and european women and so then
they said look
you're advocating so much for the rights
of these
muslim women or these brown women
what about our rights and we want this
and we want that
and we want equality here and there and
that so
basically the weapon was turned against
uh
them and we're still seeing that today
like those same kinds of
destruction like the destruction that
feminism
has wrought on uh people around the
world
and cultures around the world and now
more recently in the past hundred years
is being
turned against uh america and the west
in general
wow it's crazy
so that's like the untold story of
feminism like the idea that oh feminism
was just women who
wanted to vote like that's that's like a
cartoon caricature like that's not
really
like the true full story like the
original feminists
were the colonizers these european men
who want to save
you know quote unquote save muslim women
as an excuse to
control and take over and kill muslims
so for a muslim to be a feminist is like
the most ironic thing
and it's the most backwards and
contradictory thing
no two things could be more incompatible
and it's it's not even necessarily
subtle it's like very
obvious so and then the way that
feminism operates nowadays is to throw
shade if you want to put it like that on
the entire islamic tradition
because feminists say that look we can't
really trust
information and knowledge that's coming
from men
like that's just a male bias and that's
mansplaining
so when we have all of the greatest
scholars of islam
were men right they were men like you'll
talk about
someone like imam ibn tamiya or imam
ghazali
or ibn hajjab
and so forth there are men where's where
are the women in this not to say that
there weren't women scholars in muslim
history they were
but the top scholars just in terms of
their sheer knowledge
they were men the final messenger
muhammad he was a man so this is a
problem
for a kind of feminist equality
understanding right because you think
that
if it's coming from a man that's a male
bias and this is
patriarchy and this is structural
oppression so you'll see many of these
muslim feminists
who claim to be muslim they'll reject
all of
the islamic tradition they'll reject all
of the islamic tradition they'll say
this is just patriarchal nonsense we
don't need
the islamic tradition because it's male
bias we'll just go to the quran
itself directly but then there's a
problem because in the quran
allah the pronoun in arabic that's used
for allah is
means he so allah uses the preferred
pronoun
that is used to refer to allah by allah
in the quran is
a male pronoun so then you have some
feminists who have a problem with this
and they'll say no
my allah is a she my allah is a she
and you had rasheeda talab the
congresswoman from michigan who became
famous for some reason
as like a muslim congresswoman uh she
actually went on record and said that no
i'm a feminist and my allah is a she
so now you're disagreeing with the words
of the quran
and this is clear blasphemy you want to
change the words of the quran
so that means you have a problem at that
level so that this is how
feminism like the word i use for it's
like the road to apostasy
you get on the feminist track it might
start off simple like oh
you know i think that there needs to be
more women's
programs in the masjid or in the
community
like we need more women's programs that
could be a good
effort or a good initiative to have
resources dedicated to like
educating muslim women and so on fine
that's good
but then if you take it too far and you
start drinking the kool-aid and buying
this
ideology at its face value then step by
step by step
it's going to lead you to have
eventually have a problem with the
scholars of islam to eventually having a
problem with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because he was a man
and he had 11 wives for example
and then you're going to even have a
problem with allah himself
and you have feminists like amina wadud
she became infamous
she's an academic she wrote a book and
in that book she says we have to be able
to say no to the quran
we're going to say no to the quran
because sometimes the quran is not going
to be just
so you as an individual woman of color
a proud woman of color you should be
able to say no to the quran
so this is clear kofir martial
what a strong independent woman yeah
i feel like that's why there's such a
big with just the discussion of feminism
because
if someone were to say something like
feminism is not
islamic and then you have people who
believe that
just the very basic understanding of
feminism of you know i i want to do more
for women
and if they're marginalized in society
then you know i want to help them
and you take that in person and they
hear the statement that feminism is not
an islam
right that muslim woman is going to be
like what are you talking about and then
that muslim woman saying feminism isn't
islam the other end is going to be like
what are you talking about
like you're you know like you said
you're on the road to to apostasy now
subhanallah and i think if if if only
people knew the history because it's the
first time i heard it myself
if people know that history that it's
it's so ironic
that um the first group of feminists
were men
like it they were the white knights yeah
subhanallah it's and it's so
we can say that you say why not
i don't know what's youtube's community
guideline policy
everything and anything we're saying
anything and everything but if we do do
a transcript
and we can we can definitely write white
guys anyone watching this if you if you
work for google or adsense
when we say white knight we're talking
about like a night like the night sky
yeah all right yeah we're not talking
about like a knight and shining on
that's just a psa though
yeah when we say
simp what do we mean uh someone
in presence
someone in my presence yeah just someone
in my presence bro
okay we got we got simps everywhere
right we got we got someone in my
presence no matter where you go
so we are all sims right now i don't
have anyone in my presence right now i'm
by myself
okay i'm by myself too i'm by myself too
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right now based on what we talked so
far i want you to give us a little more
couple examples that you could think of
that feminism has been propagating and
cultivating itself in the youth because
again we know that the next generation
is going to be from the current
generation so
youth education system how is is the
school system
masculinizing women right because that's
essentially one of the goals of feminism
and emasculating men or little boys
yeah there are so many examples but as
um
you know you recognized there is there
is
a natural sense that men have of
protecting
women right and allah has put us
put that kind of sense in us that women
are more delicate
they're they're generally weaker than
men they're smaller
so we have an instinct like a father to
protect his daughter or husband to
protect his wife
like that's a good instinct that's a
natural instinct so a lot of people like
this becomes like a gateway for feminism
but what feminism does is it completely
blows it out of proportion so when we
say we're opposed to
feminism we're not saying we're opposed
to women's
rights but the question is who defines
those rights
are the people defining the rights you
know just you know random
atheists and materialists who don't even
believe in god
who may not even believe like in the
afterlife or are we going to allow allah
the creator of men
and women to define what really is a
woman's right and what's not a woman's
right
and so we have to be clear on that we're
not opposed to women's rights we just
want the proper
articulation and the proper
understanding of what women's rights are
and the only way to have a proper
understanding is to go back to what
allah says
and what was exemplified by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam as the final
messenger to mankind
so that's like there's a gateway because
of just natural male
sentiment of wanting to protect
daughters and and mothers and sisters
but you do have exactly as you mentioned
a kind of agenda against what's called
toxic masculinity
and this is a big problem masculinity is
important
because masculinity is one of the
genders that allah has
created allah has created two genders
as controversial as that might be in
2021
but uh there's just male and and female
and each one has its own
nature and if you want to live be able
to live
your life harmoniously and flourish
as a human uh race or as your family
your community
there are certain roles that are defined
and there are certain kinds of
sentiments and attitudes and
proclivities that are distinct for the
men
for males and for for women and
without that without that distinction
between the two genders
it's going to collapse and you'll have
chaos and confusion and
depression and anger resentment and
that's what we see with a lot of
men and women today because these this
the idea of gender has completely been
collapsed we're not i can't say that
you're a man and i'm a man
you're a person right you're just a
person
and you know i don't know hillary
clinton
is a person and your mom is a person you
don't have a mom and a
dad you have two parents they could be
anything they could be any gender
and you don't have to have two you can
have multiple you have like three
uh you know male identifying and four
female identifying and two non-binary
and those they can all be your parents
right but there is an objective
right and wrong answer like there is an
objective
best way to like raise children there's
an objective best way to like
have a marriage it's not like just this
free-for-all that you can just decide
whatever you want
if you do then don't be surprised if you
fall into depression if your children
in that household are more likely to be
depressed and
do drugs and have mental problems to be
abused
uh to go to jail to be unemployed like
all of these risk factors like if
if you want to argue it just from a
secular perspective and and you're
someone who doesn't care about what god
says
then look at it just from a secular
statistical point of view and you have
all of these risk factors
associated now you might say that well
this is because we haven't normalized it
in society
but there's a reason why all societies
historically
have done have had gender roles and
they've had a distinction between
male and female that's universal
so why is that okay you can't say it's
like a
cultural construction like this is just
something that has been
invented by people because if it were
invented by people then how do you
explain
how all of these people cultures
separated by time and space
independently arrived at the same answer
the same solution
for how to you know organize their
families
and how to have marriage and how to have
uh
even even something like polygamy
polygyny with man and multiple wives
that's a that exists in 75 percent of
world cultural
cultures historically that's that can
be just by chance like they're
independent they're not influencing each
other
yeah so then there must be something in
our nature
this is how we were created it's
objective
so but the feminist mentality
and some would say marxist mentality is
that no
there's no such thing as human nature
it's all just an invention it's all just
a social construction
and we can structure family and gender
and in in whatever way we want
and we should in order to maximize
equality and liberty
as as we talked about in the previous
session yeah
okay if if somebody let me just jump in
on me
if somebody came to us and said that
feminism
is a covert way of depopulating the
popular
depopulation agenda for like the human
race
i would be more likely to believe that
than to believe that it's for women's
rights
because because at the end of the day if
you're if you're coming to me and saying
that
the you know we're imposing feminism
this this and that
so that you know less people reproduce
you know men are now no longer men women
women everyone's confused we're all this
one equal
androgynous thing and you know
it's going to seize uh this whole crisis
of running out of resources
i'll be more likely to believe that than
what it is but to quickly uh
you know add on to the point that
brother daniel was making
for anyone that that hasn't caught on
these are actual statistics
men uh and just kids in general a higher
likelihood of being incarcerated
uh you know getting into gangs doing
more drugs getting into more crimes
uh not you know finishing school and you
know higher mental illness like you said
reliance on you know haram uh when
they're raised in single mom households
and you know single mom households uh
there are exceptions to this right
because you know in islam it's some not
to marry you know widows and
all that but what i'm talking about
single mom is this
i'm talking about this planned
parenthood you know modern feminism
agenda to promote single motherhood
because you got a woman who
you know she might have kids and you
know two three different baby daddies
she will get a good fat check from the
government at the end of every month
on the ninth from each of them but as
soon as you put a man in that picture
even if it's not the biological father
of those kids
she will no longer get that check so you
got the government incentivizing
women to not really worry about keeping
a man and keeping this family dynamic
yeah hold up
so you said the uh all the the sides of
you know being raised in a single mother
household but what are the sides of
being raised in a household where you
have two dads
or you have two mothers or you have like
i don't think there's a
group of people that are your your
so-called parents
yeah bro real quick i just want to
correct you i don't think it's okay in
2021 that you use those words
you should be saying parent or you know
whoa
there's no husband bro it's partner i
think the the white house passes this
new uh
bill that they they're taking out the
words brother sister father mother i'm
sure you guys have heard about it
and it's official it's this is not like
me saying something i saw on reddit so
it's crazy but i want daniel to ask you
that man if
a kid is growing up with two fathers and
you know clearly
like i'm no scientist but i would say
the kids adopted
right because you have two men what what
happens to that kid what is he gonna
grow up
seeing
um i mean there's this really
dramatizing documentary trying to get
the uh
name of the exact documentary
it's like boy with the mango
tattoo or tree tattoo have you heard of
this that says
i think i've seen it yeah i think i've
seen it you've seen it right about these
two guys that adopted the boy and they
were basically
uh abusing him like it's a really
traumatic story
it's very traumatic like sexually
abusing yeah
yeah they were like trafficking him
and it was like a huge case uh out of
australia
um maybe someone in the comments can
post there someone can look it up real
real quick boy with the something tattoo
anyway i might have a terrible memory
but this is like a really traumatic
documentary
and you can't really look at the
statistics
when it comes to child abuse in some of
these kinds of
marriages and it's
like politically incorrect so nothing
gets published on the actual official
stats
but every now and then a story comes out
or a documentary like this comes out
and it shows like the reality of what
that is like there's a it's really angry
angering and shocking so
i mean people can go look that up or
maybe someone can post it in the
comments but um
yeah if you if you have children of
yours your own like go and watch that
documentary and you won't be able to
sleep
for at least a few days it will make you
so angry
but yeah i mean we can talk about all
kinds of risk factors associated
uh with children who are born uh or
are raised in this kind of uh same-sex
uh marriage and what i have
can cite is a study that was published
that says that
um there's a i think seven times or
eleven times more likelihood of being
sexually molested
and abused uh when you're for children
who are in those
in those households so i mean these are
facts
and it's not surprising because as you
mentioned like you they can't both be
biological
right so then they're not biological
then
okay what's the other side is a stranger
and oftentimes you'll find that
these same-sex marriages like what
percentage of
uh opposite sex couples do you think
cheat
like they're married and lower they
cheat i think lower than same-sex
like yeah it's it's about um
like 15 less than 20
okay so about 75 they're faithful like
they're not going to cheat
but there's like 25 to 15 percent
who will cheat on even though they're
married adultery zinna
when it comes to same sex 96
96 and this is because they just have
a lot more partners right that's just
the lifestyle
so the average gay man will have uh
in his life 500 partners
or more and most of them are anonymous
and this is something that i talk about
i mean we're getting into a different
topic now with lgbt
but the average non-muslim man
will have maybe six partners in his
whole life
non-muslim six uh opposite sex partners
yeah yeah yeah gay men will have
500 and then a certain percentage like
20
of gay men will have over a thousand
partners
and that's just like gay lifestyle
that's what the lifestyle is about
is a lot of anonymous sex with strangers
like going to the club
and and doing that and from a biological
perspective like
there's a really good balance between
men and women right
because men are the testosterone is
driving them to be
aggressive like to pursue relationships
and they want
they typically have higher libido and
women will
restrict right uh reproductive access
more so because the a woman is selective
in who she partners up with right and
that's the case for muslim
non-muslims like women are just more
selective right they don't
don't just sleep with anyone uh and and
they're hypergamous which will i guess
we'll get into
but if you have men who are more
aggressive and they want sex with other
men who also want more sex
together then that's going to mean a lot
and a lot and a lot of
of this kind of uh man-on-man
activity hold on then being into
graphics
there's a lot of gay dudes out there
that aren't really you know masculine
men bro they got a lot of that feminine
energy got
the estrogen man so i don't know but
like i do see that where it's like
um as a guy i think something that
prevents us from wanting to have so much
sex is the fact that like we can get a
woman pregnant
you know and this is speaking like as if
someone wasn't a muslim
obviously as a muslim you're not gonna
think that oh i'm gonna have sex with
every single girl i find
but it's like even even though that's
like in our dna to spread our seed
like we still have that in the back of
our mind where it's like ah
if i have sex with x amount of girls
like there is a huge possibility that
x amount of girls are going to get
pregnant versus if
you have this gay dude and he's like oh
well i could have sex with 500 dudes
and none of these dudes are gonna get
pregnant so i'm
i'm good exactly exactly that's a great
point
so i mean that those are the statistics
so
it's uh there's so then how can you
really have
a stable childhood like growing up in
that kind of environment when you're
you know your dad is engaging that kind
of behavior like what
what kind of effect will that have on
you you can really talk about that like
you might have to like edit this video
because i don't know if it's going to
be bad bro we say everything and
anything
no 100 i know we can't we can say
anything and everything but that
don't mean that youtube is going to keep
it up
but not we'll definitely we'll if we do
talk go end up more about lgbt
we'll make like a separate video on it
then but you know
to address your points that you know a
lot of people might not be on the same
page
picking up what he was putting down
about why women are more selective and
choosy
is because think about it a woman can
get pregnant maximum
once per month right because she
ovulates one
one time per month and even then when
she ovulates and if she does get
pregnant she's
she's what she's out of commission for
nine ten months until that baby's out
for a man if you give him 10 months
he can theoretically create the whole
human race
we're not even going to get into that
but he doesn't need to be so choosy
as in a sperm cell is not as as valuable
biologically genetically as as an exo so
men can therefore afford to prioritize
more of uh and i believe it's like an
art strategist approach where it's like
they have they can have more kids and
not put too much
emphasis on each kid whereas a woman she
needs to go for that highest value man
now this is a wonderful time to go into
hypergamy because we we did
kind of delve into it a bit in the past
but i know a lot of people are watching
they're like what is this
hypergamy thing i've heard about
monogamy i've heard about polygamy
i've even heard about this weird thing
y'all muslims practice called polygyny
but i don't know what high program is is
it like
you have too many wives or like how does
that go so
um yeah man why don't we go into that
yeah i mean you've described it
perfectly like the reason for it like
the biological basis
for it uh women have to be more choosy
and they need to uh mate with a man
who they feel is going to be able to
provide for her when she's out of
commission when she's pregnant
and will not only protect her
and provide for her in that weekend
state but will also take care of her
children
and will provide for them and make sure
they have enough food to eat they have
shelter and
they're protected from uh enemies and
from predators
so you need us so as a as a woman you're
prioritizing having
uh that kind of strong male provider and
then there are certain indications of
what makes a strong man
and who will be best to reproduce with
so
one is physical size if the guy is just
taller if the guy is just bigger
okay that's something that she will be
attracted to naturally like it's not
necessarily conscious some of these
factors some of it is conscious like
six foot six packs six figures okay
that's conscious because the women
are saying that on instagram or wherever
or on tick tock or their
uh what's tinder profiles but
the uh a lot of it could be unconscious
as well so
wanting a guy who is tall
his wealth like how much is he making
how much
resources that does he have his status
so like if he's higher status uh even if
he might not be the best looking guy
but he's like bill gates okay then that
there's an attraction there because
female attraction
is not purely physical in the same way
that
men's attraction is right because again
it's
all kind of boils down to that
reproductive strategy that you laid out
at the beginning
uh so like your status even like being
funny
like guys who are funnier appear
more attractive to women like being able
to being good with words
performing in front of people like
that's considered that's seen as being
higher status
and so that status is what attracts
women so hypergamy basically means that
a woman is always looking for
someone who is higher than her in status
so achieve that a particular status like
you can rank like my rank
from a 1 to 10 is a 5.
so if i'm a 5 as a woman i'm looking for
a 6
7 8 9 10. ideally i'd like a 10 if a 10
will have me as a five but i'm looking
i'm not paying attention to the fives
the men who are fives i'm not paying
attention to the men who are
fours threes twos and ones okay
and you know their and their calculation
is based on
mainly status and indications of status
and
physical size and so forth this is
common sense
right and then men will have a different
calculus
but they're also thinking like i'm a man
who's a five
i'm looking i'd love to be with a 10 a
woman who's a 10
and the man's calculation is
primarily based on looks there are other
factors as well but
that's the main thing we don't care
about status i don't care as a man
how much money you make i don't care as
a man you know how many degrees you have
that doesn't matter to me i care about
the person i'll say that
my bad for cutting you up but second
person to say that keep going bro
yeah so i'm i'm talking like just purely
from a non-muslim standpoint
obviously for marriage purposes
islamically there are
more you have to look more than just
looks right yeah and if you're a woman
you look more than just
wealth and status you have to prioritize
dean
and the person's relationship with allah
of course
i'm not denying that but what is the
biological
component of it like what do does our
biology drive us to
and that's something that is not in your
control
right if a 10 walks by
right you're going to look you'll have
that you'll have the
uh impetus to want to look but then
it's dean and taqwa that tells you to
lower your gaze
right but you still have that natural uh
impulse and that's the thing for men and
women when this
when the millionaire drives up in the
lamborghini in the lambo on the street
the woman can look right and she'll have
the
she'll want to look who's that guy who's
that high value guy who's driving the
lambo
she'll have that kind of sentiment but
it's dean that says no lower your gaze
you're
married or lower your gaze you shouldn't
be like looking at guys
strange guys driving up in the lambo so
this is
this is what hypergamy is in a nutshell
you uh
you're saying you got you can't be
looking at a guy you're married we got
married girls in clubs today bro
and fellas daniel is dropping a hell of
a lot of game right now and i know
a lot of you might not be fully you know
on the same page but everything he's
saying it's it's
it's not just what we're saying from
islam it's also biologically or
secularly
proven right you got promiscuity at an
all-time high
eighty percent of women sleep with
twenty percent of men if that's not
hypergamy i don't know what is
and hypergamy is is aligned with this
dualistic imperative that women have
they simultaneously need to secure the
highest value offspring
and simultaneously make sure that the
highest value offspring survives
because there's no point if you can you
know mate with a high quality
you know male like daniel's talking
about that high status ideal guy
with the 666 i wonder where i've heard
that from as well
but there's no point having that kid but
then the kid dies like a month or two
after he's born right stuck for a lot so
you gotta simultaneously as women
they need to secure both and oftentimes
today we live in a very disparate
society where
you know men are very very in how they
are you got some men that
are growing up to they're 30 40 50 and
they've never even you know interacted
with a woman
and you've gotten a guy obviously you
know we don't condone this in islam but
by 1819 he has like a
you know a body count of like 30. so you
know
men today are not the same and you know
society has a large
you know role to play with that we're
not going to talk about positive factors
but
essentially to sum up his point because
there's so many men
that are not that guy that guy that you
know me and i know keep talking about
because there's so many men that are not
being that guy that is everything he is
simultaneously
you know physically the the highest
value male but also
you know he can provide he can protect
women today
will not be with that same guy women
have incentive
of mating you know obviously like you
know out of islam we're talking about
you know
most promiscuous cultures today in the
modern day they will mate with just high
value men
but then they also want that guy who's
like stable and like you know
a provider and i feel like a girl's a
woman's you know ovulation cycle has a
lot to do with that and
people people don't know about these
things but when you see what a woman
finds attractive
during the first two weeks of her cycle
she will find
more alpha you know dominant traits
attractive
she will find that that man you're
talking about the six foot guy six-pack
she'll find this more attractive as soon
as she's done ovulating the second half
of the month
she will find kind of the opposite
traits attractive she will find someone
who's more of a provider
attractive who has more wealth more
attractive than the beginning
and this is because biologically
speaking if she got pregnant when she
ovulated right her body doesn't know
that she got pregnant until the next you
know cycle
so you know evolutionarily she needs to
like now okay cool i got pregnant
call us now i gotta make sure this kid
grows up and he's straight he's
you know obviously secure he's going to
be healthy so now i got to automatically
seek that provider that protected that
provisioner
and women today are not they don't
realize that but
what islam and i know um brother daniel
talked about hypergamy in the
in the debate i'm gonna say debate with
uh apus
he talked about it clearly and he said
that that as men
and you know in islam islam limits this
hypergamy
and you know allows a woman to have both
of her imperatives met with one man
and women don't want to hear this today
they say oh why can't i have four
husbands
you know or you know what's wrong with
the woman being the provider so i want
you to answer these two questions
i mean why can't you have four husbands
like what kind of husbands are you going
to have
like there was this a new story about
exactly this situation
a woman with four husbands
and i'm not gonna describe what the
woman looked like
um but let's just say like you wouldn't
want like
it wouldn't be difficult for you to
lower your gaze but uh
the four uh guys i mean
we're talking losers like they were just
not attractive at all in any sense
and they have to be losers because they
can't get their like
that a woman to commit to
uh for them by themselves right
so they have to share they're not that's
how low status they are
so the thing about hypergamy is that
women are not attracted to women to men
at the same
status and they're definitely not
attracted to these kinds of
wimpy weak men who are
are willing to share share them right
and in literature you hear all kinds of
stories and literature and art about a
woman
like a high value princess and the men
have to fight to the death for her right
they have to duel or they have to like
fight over her right
i mean it's cringy yeah that's true but
the idea is that she's gonna go home
with one guy at the end of the day
right it would be kind of anti-climactic
it wouldn't be a romantic story
if the two guys instead of fighting to
the death said hey
hey man why are we fighting why don't we
just share we'll just be buddies
and let's just like hug it out that
would be like an anticlimactic
very wimpy non-masculine revolting kind
of solution
which is why we don't see those kinds of
stories in in literature
so women themselves would not want
they would not be attracted to these
kinds of
men that agree to be co-husbands
because those type of men are you know
you can just imagine
them that's why they have to do it all
in secret like if they want to cheat
and have like multiple side pieces they
have to cheat
in order to do that because if one of
the guys finds out
he's not going to stand for it he's
going to leave her right i'm not going
to be
like some uh i'm going to be played like
that right
but with women that's not the case like
many
women will consciously agree
like okay i will be a second wife
i will be a third wife or for
non-muslims i will be like a groupie or
i'll i will be a side piece
side chick for this guy because he's you
know
high status he's high value he's like a
lebron james or whoever
uh jeff bezos whatever
because he's at that level i'm fine with
being the
second wife third wife fourth wife so
again it goes back to hypergamy it goes
back to
women's nature and man's nature so when
women say that oh why can't i have four
husbands
it's not like something that they really
want they just want to make like a
counter example or an argument against
polygamy that's that's it
they wouldn't really want to have that
kind of situation and
just look at these pictures of actual
couples or not couples but
families where it's one woman and
multiple men and see if that's the kind
of
life that you want to live 100 man
oh and then actually with that with that
couple actually uh i posted on my social
media this one time
but what happened is after they reported
a year later the the woman got pregnant
okay she got pregnant and then one of
these co-husbands
ended up killing the babies
so like very it's a very it's a very
inherently
natural thing to comprehend because one
the reason islam guys and girls that
don't understand this whole thing about
why men can be politionist and we don't
have
polyandry is because hold up take your
glasses off before you answer this
hi bro all right
as i was saying bro you look at you look
at men
you look at women none of those met in
that relationship with that woman
i'm not talking exclusively to the man
that danny was talking about that
uh you know killed the daughter i
believe it was a very young like infant
too
um you know and the baby was just doing
whatever the baby was doing right
um the guy was alone with that with that
baby
right the mom or the wife was not home
the co-husbands were not home and he did
exactly what
is kind of inherent because one none of
those four guys have guaranteed
paternity of the kid
now this is very controversy of
controversy um
contrary to what you see in islam see
islam
doesn't allow a woman to have four
husbands because then there's no
guaranteed paternity
we we look at kinship and inheritance
because these are
important fundamentals in islam and it's
it's the way of the sunnah
and when you look at one woman with four
four men you don't know who's the father
you don't know who
who has paternity but if you have one
man with four women
it's it's almost guaranteed you know
that it all came you know you know who
the mom is and you know what the dad is
with all of them
right because women never have to go
through that that same thing that men
have to go through i know this is a
little bit of an off comment but
i know bro if you have if you have a kid
with a with a woman with a wife
right yeah inshallah bro she doesn't
cheat on you but
if you don't do a paternity dna test you
cannot guarantee to me that
that's your son you can't bro
a woman yeah go on go ahead no sorry i
didn't mean to cut you off no no you're
good i was just like a woman
never have to have that that worry right
yeah there's
markers that we can have as men to like
you know look at morphologically but for
women
they know if this came out of me 50 of
the genes are for me so 100 it's my kid
at least
whereas a man you idealistically can
maximally have 50
if you know it's your wife but minimally
it could be zero because it might not
even be your kid
yeah exactly um this is like relevant
like uh in islam you mentioned like
understanding
your nessa understanding like where you
come from
is very important and this is actually
one of the makasid of the sharia like
one of the aims of the sharia is to
preserve nasib
and it's something that even non-muslims
can easily understand
right because imagine not knowing who
your father is that can be very
traumatic
and i mean some people it's not their
fault but they just don't know like who
their father is
and their lives are harder because of
that um
it's you always want to know your
origins like that's a human instinct
that we all have
but another very important thing with
paternity and knowing
your nessa biologically is that
uh fathers or men who know
like the signs of paternity are there
like they are sure or they're very
highly confident
that that child is his
they're going they have more natural
feelings of love
and more natural feelings of affection
and feelings of wanting to sacrifice and
put their own lives on the line
for their own children and again this is
not conscious
and it's not cultural either because you
find this across
all cultures and you even find this uh
in the animal kingdom
as well where the males if they
are they feel more confident in their
paternity
uh they're going to be much more
invested
in the marriage and then more invested
in the
child so this has actual tangible
consequences in a society where
paternity
is constantly being mixed up because
people are promiscuous and they're
getting knocked up without being married
and now with like
sperm donation and adoption like they
adopt
kids okay in islam it's permissible to
adopt kids but the
parents adopting the people adopting
pretend like they're the biological
parents
right and then only later does the child
find out oh these aren't my biological
parents i actually have different
parents
so this is like deception that islam
doesn't allow but
point being like if you have a society
with all of these things happening then
paternity is constantly being mixed up
and so you're going to have adults who
care less about children
and are less protected protective of
children and less
invested in children as opposed to
islamic society
it's going to be more invested in
children more protective more stable
households so these kinds of rules in
islam
about not doing zinna not committing
zina
about keeping gender separate so there's
not even much
chance of falling into zinna with people
those are actually there's infinite
number of
wisdoms behind that that you can see uh
in the world around us today
it's very true i just want to throw this
in man like this
this is far back because like we all
just kept talking i didn't want to
interrupt
because it was so good but um thinking
back in terms of like women and men like
women are so choosy like you said
where you have a five and like she's
gonna try to get anything above that
but she's not gonna stand for something
that's like at her level or below
but it's like you have a guy who's a
five like
he'll take anything you get you know
like i mean maybe he might not go for
the one or two but it's like look if he
can't get anything better than that like
he'll accept it yeah that's a lot
yeah that's why like the situation now
uh where you said like 20 of guys are
with 80
of women that's exactly because of what
you're saying
because the though the women because of
tinder
and just hookup culture if she
is a five right she can get with a 10
for one night
right she matches on tinder with a 10.
the 10 is fine okay i'm gonna be with
you for one night
i don't care if you're a five i don't
care if you're a four it's just like a
one night stand i'm just getting it
but then who is he gonna marry though
right who is that
10 when he has to get married who is he
going to make a commitment to he's going
to make a commitment to the other 10
right not to a four so then that four
is going to be like why can't i get
married to these guys that i'm
used to sleeping with i'm used to
sleeping with these one night stands
with
eight nines and tens but now when it's
time to get married
i can't find a good guy a high value man
there's no good men out there it's
because her sense of
uh she she's really a four but because
she's been getting with these eight
nines and ten she thinks she's much
higher in value than she really is
and so she's it's like a rude awakening
like i can't find
the husband that i want i just have
these loser options basically
and she doesn't realize and then what
happens is she gets like in her 30s late
30s
then she has to settle she thinks she's
settling but it's really a guy who's
much better
than her and then yeah she's going to be
depressed she's gonna feel like she's
settled and she's with a loser
and those marriages end up being very
sad and depressing and
she ends up leaving him eventually and
she might be like one of these single
moms again
single moms we're not using that as a
pejorative sense but
we're talking about these independent
women who they slept around
their whole lives they went through like
how many
notches in their bedpost and they might
even have a kid
and now they can't get with the tens so
they have to find some guy
who is going to be like a beta to
provide
for them and to keep maintain like their
lifestyle so some poor guy
doesn't know that he maybe has only been
with a few women in
his life as a non-muslim but his wife
with a child
has been with maybe dozens of guys
with um who are in higher status than he
is
so it's a very depressing situation
subhanallah man i know so many women
that they're in a relationship or a
marriage
married to this guy who's quote-unquote
that beta like you said
she kind of felt like she settled for
him yeah she had a man you know maybe
he's not here right now
for whatever reason and now they kind of
got this guy
and it's it wasn't her fault but it's
like now to the point where she is
that guy's not gonna do it she's not
used to that like you said she's used to
that tent
or she's used to something else these
women if if they don't already cheat
they're more likely to cheat
and again their their provisioner
provider protector type of
thing is meant for the you know the
dualistic imperative but
that man that they they desire
physically sexually they don't have that
so they're more likely to cheat on on
them with that and conversely
women that have that that man that
you're talking about the the one who
physically is what they want i'm not
saying if they have that they won't
cheat on him
with the beta but they're at least more
less likely to cheat
because the reason people cheat
primarily is physical
right so if you're already met in that
aspect you don't really need
to cheat with the guy who's that but
yeah you're right man
uh brother daniel was 100 on that you
got women that are 30 they hit the wall
and now they're kind of wondering okay
i'm used to this type of caliber of matt
but this type of caliber man doesn't
want me anymore right
and they are they feel like they already
peaked and now their clocks running out
they feel like they got to secure that
man
but they can't find it right and i feel
like to end off the point that brother
danny was talking about a big reason
that has to do
and we already talked about it women
only date up or marry up
in islam and in any culture if
women are out here pursuing high degrees
right i'm not against women in education
that's not the point but
women are out here pursuing really high
education i'm talking about grad school
level
let's say they're a doctor or a lawyer
or something right
that alone because of hypergamy because
women only marry up
that limits the amount of men that are
higher than her relatively in terms of
status because women look for status
significantly right you got a woman
who's used to just sleeping with eights
nines and tens
she's not gonna that what do you know
the average man is what like a five or
six
so that's gonna limit that even more
right so feminism
is creating a bunch of women who are
basically so masculine so up here in
value or at least they think they are
they're conditioned to think they are
that they can't find a guy anymore
because most guys are not going to be at
that top one percent level
uh that's not the truth with men on
average that i've seen i'm sure angela
and ramy can relate to this
how many guys do you know that are like
maybe sevens or eights they just don't
realize it
they're out here simply for like a two
or three they're out here compromising
islam for the chick they're out here
compromising their own manhood their
integrity and they don't realize they're
doing it bro
romney do you want to add something
i mean there was a lot one to say
throughout the entire conversation but
like angel said i don't want to
interrupt it because you know it was um
but allah oh no the first thought is
like imagine if everybody was just
humble
right you know no one looked at
themselves like oh i'm a 10. you know
i'm amazing
and obviously there's a fine line
between knowing your self-worth
and um just being arrogant and thinking
you're amazing and better than other
people
um but subhanallah it's just it's all it
feels like it's all deception at the end
of the day it doesn't help that we live
in a very
um you know consumerist type society i
saw a video the other day where
you know the the one was talking about
how women are like products
and men are like the consumer right
which is why
what was it like women make up 80 of the
of consumers
right i think i think yeah about that
yeah so they're
buying all these products because
they're becoming the product themselves
for men
essentially and men are just essentially
buying them with whatever
you know high value they have and it
just all seems like delusion at the end
of the day because what are they really
working towards
like if is that your ultimate goal in
life it just
what do you what do you say to women
that are gonna refute your point and say
oh all this makeup i i do that for me or
i'm dressed this way for me yeah then
then why don't you settle for someone
who's a three if you think you're a five
if you know like why are you true if why
are you putting it on
and and you know not going for someone
at the same level as you when the makeup
is off
right why yeah and what what do you
achieve for yourself
when you because you know there are
other ways to feel good about yourself
why don't you go work out
right why don't you uh save up and and
given charity there are other ways to
feel better about yourself rather than
you know
putting makeup on your face and i'm not
saying you know makeup inherently is
horrible
there are certain contexts where you
know it could be good for you to wear
makeup like if you want to
you know look even better for your
husband there's nothing wrong with that
dude i think makeup should be bam bro
you have women out here
put makeup on and they appear like
they're like seven or eights and then
once they take that makeup off
surprise they're like a two or three bro
it's like yo yeah
that's also a form of deception which is
this yeah man
brother brother gabriel romani made a
video about that on igtv
about women having you know we got
filters today
filters that manipulate how you look you
got fillers you got apps like facetune
you got makeup like on angel was talking
about that should be banned
um i'm not saying i agree i'm not saying
i disagree but the point that we're
getting at
is it's just hiding what you really are
and we do too much of that you're not
you only feel comfortable and confident
like that you don't feel you when you're
not with them
like for men we can't relate like well i
can't even say we don't wear makeup
anymore because
you got dudes wearing makeup now but i'm
saying the average man that's still like
us that's in their frame in their
aligned with their fitnah we don't go
out with makeup if we don't feel
okay about how we look tell us man we
could do something about our body
but with little things like that we
can't we don't put on foundation and you
know all that stuff
so but you want to know some crazio
genetically speaking the male
species is actually more attractive
than the female species and that can be
seen in many
different animals bro look at the
peacocks
the male peacock is the one that has all
the beautiful feathers
and the female peacock is this ugly
abomination bro
looks like some burnt turkey burnt
turkey boy and like if you look at women
in humans like it's very rare that you
get a girl that's like
an eight nine ten like subscriber like
it's very rare that that happens when
they're like that with no makeup
but what you're saying like i'm just i'm
not saying like anything like
suggesting dudes to like go after other
dudes that's that's homosexual bro
what i'm saying is that like if you look
at it
in a non-homosexual way
mostly dudes are the ones that are
raking
higher up in the scales because most
dudes don't use makeup
yeah there there are two things i want
to add to that point
um firstly i want to say there are two
aspects right because one
who is looking at the who is looking at
these women right it's men
and i feel like our perception of beauty
nowadays especially with makeup and the
societal concepts of what's beautiful is
so high
that it's just harder for women to to
kind of meet that standard especially
when
you look at like porn stars and these
very promiscuous you know
these disgusting industries whereas for
women we men haven't been
put on that you know yeah that scale
yet on that scale you have to look this
way right we're still here bro
what are you talking about what about
brad pitt and tom yeah
yeah but they're not athletes yeah or
but that's the thing okay yeah there's a
very good looking man allah but they're
not just good-looking men
they're like you said athletes and and
stars and
and yeah they're rich yeah but
yeah that's my point but they they have
more of a high value in terms of
societal
high value but talking about looks alone
that oh
okay it's not the biggest deal for men
to just look that way
so it's i feel like it's more of a
perception thing
right i got more men are perceived to be
attractive than women are perceived to
be attractive because for women they
have to be up here to look attractive
for men you don't have to be up there
but there's a lot of address
yeah to address anno's point bro this
whole penis everything we're talking
about
women just wanting to be men with
feminism this is another example bro
makeup to be more attractive because
just like you said boy in nature
i'm not sure about empirical studies but
i don't doubt that
male species are on average more
attractive than women
that's the first point sisters before
you you think we're just attacking you
bear with us because we're gonna we're
gonna bring everything full circle and
give you some game too
but bismuth address romney's point
romney what were you just talking about
how you got the average man who is of
high status
high wealth and all this compared with
you know paired with the good looks that
we're talking about
he's the top 1 but you're saying a woman
with just looks alone can get so much
further in society i agree
a woman today with just looks can get
anywhere i'm talking about living life
on recruit mode
right and this isn't like some attack on
y'all but
this is real stuff and you look at islam
you look at
you know the way you know we're supposed
to be as men and women we have our roles
we're not
trying to you know become one another
trying to you know
be more than we are seem like you know
we're more valuable than we are
it does tie into the humility that
brother robert was talking about
everyone has this big ego today right
and you know before we go in on women
and kind of you know
tell them the approach that is more
resourceful and conducive
let's talk to men bro let's give a nice
message to all the brothers watching us
right now
because we got we got men you know i'm
not gonna expose any people
obviously with names but we got men that
are out here sleeping with
multiple women that they call you know
you guys already know what i'm about to
say they call them that they call them
you know promiscuous and
i'll say promiscuous to be you know a
little more youtube friendly
they call them promiscuous and yet they
keep sleeping with them
and they're like oh almost all girls are
like this
but they don't realize every time you
sleep with a girl that you don't have an
intention on
a commitment with you're creating
another one of those girls
they don't they don't get that yeah
yeah that's very true i had a friend
who uh would call women [ __ ]
and he would say that um
that none of them wanted relationships
none of them
were serious they were all jokes
and then he would go on to uh have sex
with prostitutes
i was like that's kind of backwards man
you know you're saying that about women
but then you're over here paying to have
sex with a woman
yeah yeah i feel like a lot of things i
think most things in society start
you know with with men right um and the
good things in society should start with
men because i
if we are the leaders right and a lot
that's the reason allah gave us
um not status over women but
responsibility over them
in in many regards it's because um
we naturally are created to be you know
those leaders so if we're leading
everyone in the wrong direction right if
we're being promiscuous
uh it takes two to tango that means
women are being more promiscuous
but then we're gonna throw it back on
them even though we're looking at the
end results
right like we create this problem that
kind of starts with us
and then we go back on them once they
start being promiscuous and we throw it
on them and say
you know looking at the end result
saying that like it's kind of their
fault they shouldn't be that way
but if i feel like if every man society
uh fundamentally was proper
i feel like the women would essentially
have to follow that
same way if every man is kind of lost
and broken in society
the women inevitably would follow that
as well but this is something that even
feminine
feminism would cut out because it's kind
of like we don't need men to be leaders
right so you you take a masculine man
who's supposed to be a leader
and you emasculate him where are you
going to get in society
because you you kind of cut off the
means of a progression
it's taking the responsibility away from
a man and putting it on to a woman
when it's biologically in that and you
know our dispositions it's not supposed
to be that way
how are we supposed to benefit from that
brother
you you see women that are probably
gonna find this video from one of
daniel's you know subscribers or they're
gonna
find those from one of your tech talks
let's say or on ig
they find this video they hear all this
they come with all these preconceived
notions about
okay i know islam undeniably is a
patriarchal religion all right i'm not
gonna deny that guys we're not gonna
make things up
undoubtedly allah gave men authority
over women
after allah i got authority over my
woman
now this doesn't mean you know something
in some sexist sense or anything like
that
but this is what it is this is islam now
with that power comes
responsibility right and i'm not talking
about i got
you know after allah i have authority
over women i'm talking about like
every man has that authority that
responsibility over their women
not you know next man's woman because we
got
porn plots today that it's so it's
normalizing
affairs it's normalizing infidelity do
you guys feel like that has something
to do porn as a whole with why
successful relationships and marriages
are not lasting
i'll let uh daniel address that first
yeah go ahead daniel
to bring it back to feminism i think the
reason that a lot of these marriages are
failing
is because of feminist standards of
equality
because they give this idea
that men and women husband and wife
should be partners
equal partners within a marriage
and this is the gold standard like an
equality marriage that feminism promotes
but because of hypergamy this actually
goes contrary to
women's nature right and this is
contrary to what women
are attracted to so if you have
a marriage between two equal status like
five and a five
or seven and a seven that marriage is
going to be less stable
that marriage is going to be less
successful
statistically why it's because of the
women thinking just naturally that they
have settled
they have settled for a man lower than
what they really want
in terms of status in terms of hype
having that hypergamic hype pergamos
instinct so
you have these kinds of marriages
they're on the basis of equality
and what happens sometimes is that a
woman is actually being more successful
in her job and she's progressing the
corporate ladder
and as that happens the guy is not
progressing at the same level or he's
maybe even dropping maybe he loses his
job and then for some reason the woman
says
look i'm not attracted to this guy
anymore he's just not doing it for me
the excitement has left my life she
won't necessarily
know that it's because of this
discrepancy and status
it's again it's all unconscious but her
husband is just not as attractive in her
eyes as before because of that change in
status so feminism is actually
encouraging
the like the breaking of all of these
marriages because it's going so contrary
to
hypergamy um and women themselves like
that women could if the feminist
movement were serious they could end
a patriarchy in a day they could
completely end patriarchy because all
the women have to do
is say that guess what i'm going to
marry men
who are lower in status than me i'm
going to go
and marry i'm a i'm a six i'm going to
marry the two
i'm a seven i'm going to marry the three
if all
women decided to do that collectively
they could end
patriarchy and end you know all of this
abuse that men are doing
supposedly because they would be the
more powerful ones in all of their
marriages
but they don't do that why do they not
do that and you can ask
you know and sometimes if i give a talk
i'll just make a general comment like
women think for yourselves
would you be would you want a man who is
smaller than you like physically smaller
physically weaker who is less
intelligent than you
who is less confident than you who has a
lower job than you
is that something that you're looking
for or are you looking for a 666 and
whatever
so this is just women themselves like
their preferences it's not necessarily
like
islam is acknowledging the reality
of this and you you mentioned you know
the uh ayah from surah nisa al-rijal
um but also in hadith like this idea of
status
is acknowledged by the prophet alaihi
wasallam
and this is a hadith basically to
paraphrase that says that
status is considered and suitability
is a consideration in marriage
and this is actually called cafe
and you'll have books of phil that talk
about how
there's a responsibility of the wali of
the
of the daughters of a woman's father
or her grandfather or male relatives
to ensure that she is married to someone
who is of suitable status
right if she is marrying someone who is
of less
status because of he doesn't have enough
money or he is not
you know of a honorable uh background
then that's actually a reason where that
marriage shouldn't happen like because
why that's infringing on the rights
of the daughter that's infringing on her
rights
to not be married to someone who is of
suitable status
cafe so this is something that is also
found in islam like we're not just
talking about like
red pill men's right stuff this is also
uh within our own religious tradition
would you all i want romney to say
something but
i want romney to answer this bro from
your experience all right
just women you've known in your life it
doesn't have to be
you know women that were ex-wives of
yours bro
i'm talking about women in general that
you've witnessed maybe family maybe
friends you don't need to say any names
but aren't when they are in their
feminine right when they're surrounded
by men
that are being met that they don't have
to be the man
yeah aren't they happier on average
don't they look more relaxed and more
more girly you know 100 genuinely they
do
and when they you know contrary to when
they don't have that there it seems like
they're always on edge or
stress they feel like they have this
burden on them and then you can kind of
see it in them they feel like this
burden shouldn't even be on them to
begin with
um but we live in a dane and age where
it's kind of like if they were to say
something like you know a man should
take this burden from me you know
they're they're
alienated because now they're saying
something that's so contrary to what's
politically correct
um and this is also going against female
nature and i see it all the time
and it's really unfortunate and a lot of
women just don't want to admit it but
why why would it be bad right i don't
want to go off on attention there was
something i wanted
to to mention before but that's
basically the uh
the answer to the your question
okay yeah i know you've got something to
say
yeah i mean i'm i noticed this with my
mom
well i remember like she told me that
when she was married
to my dad uh she would want to do
something in the house like let's say
she wanted to uh install a new fan
change the uh front door or
paint the room or something like that
she would ask him
to like help her because like he didn't
do any of that stuff
and i was like as a man like well even
if you don't like doing that like
still do it because it's your
responsibility
and my dad wouldn't do that he's like oh
just wait like well
i'm like i'll help you later and um my
mom would just go and do it by herself
so basically she had to be masculine
in that situation and she hated it bro
she hated it
and then here she is with me like we
were over here changing the front door
and she was saying that she was gonna
change the front door and i was like you
know what
i'm gonna help you out i'm gonna help
you out because
i'm your son i'm staying with you at the
moment so
i'm the man of this house and i
literally
as i'm like doing everything for her um
i grab
something then she's like holding that
and i'm like oh let me see that drill
bit right
there i grab the drill bit and i grab
this and then as soon as
i'm going to grab something she like
pulls it away and she's like oh i can do
it myself like she got real emotional
and i was like excuse me like you see me
doing this right now like just submit
like give me the drill bit and let me
finish i didn't say like that i was you
know
proper to my mom i love my mom but like
i looked at it i was like
i was like stop like why are you being
so masculine
and then like she realized like it hit
her like oh
i've been this way because i've never
had a man
or any kind of man to just like do this
for me because her dad wasn't
in her life and then her husband wasn't
a man in her relationship so it's it's
crazy
yeah bro same exact thing happened to me
multiple occasions me and my mom
because my mom was was in the same
situation where she kind of did all the
the
you know um physical labor housework in
the house
um every time i go to help her me and my
mom cannot work together
it's just too like it seems like two
equal leaders trying to fight
each other on every split thing and it
doesn't work and sometimes it gets the
point where i'm just like mom
leave i'm gonna do this myself get out
go let me finish it
and um i i see the same thing in her
that she just wants to do herself
because she's been that way for so long
but she's so much happier when i tell
her to leave and i do it myself
when she comes back and just sees the
the finished result she's just
a lot happier so i i feel you on that
one man
man it's like i told my mom i was like
look
stop trying to be so messy and like i'm
your son
i'm a man you have a man right here
who's doing this
for you you do not have to do anything
all you have to do is literally whatever
it is that you want to do or you can sit
here and talk with me while i'm doing
this but like i'm doing this for you
it's like just let me be the man and she
literally like after
she heard that and after i was just like
reasonable with her
and like basically i brought logic but
in an emotional way to her where like
i guess it was catering to her emotions
but still
logical by nature so um yeah to answer
your question bro i'm not gonna keep it
bro
let me ask one question i want daniel
the answer first and then i want
two of you to give me your take the
woman that's been watching so far
that you know vibes with daniel vibes
with romney vibes with me bob's with
everything i know i was saying
and she can relate she's lived her life
handled you know just been around
[ __ ]
and she just never had a man all right
and she never had a man that was just in
charge taking care of
what it means to be a man so she had to
kind of be that man
and it's deep she's realizing that
cognitive dissonance that paradigm shift
she's kind of vibing with what we're
saying but she's kind of like dude what
okay if i don't do it then no one's
gonna do it there's no there's no real
men anymore
um what do i do so what is your you guys
advice
starting with brother daniel that to
give this woman that's kind of falling
so far but
she's so used to being the man wearing
the pants
that it's almost like being in the
feminine
is kind of abnormal for her and this is
not for the woman that
already has a man that's you know a
proper man subhanallah but i'm talking
about
the average woman today
is she's trying to find her mind you
said she's not trying to find a man
no she doesn't have a proper man and
she's combined that with
years of conditioning of her having to
be the man what is your advice
for her to unlearn this this behavior
oh okay is this common like there are a
lot of i know that
in for mothers like there are a lot of
mothers
even in my family i know where it's a
mother and she
has to be the man essentially like she
does all the physical things
do you mean like that's high level but
with the younger generation i don't see
that like
younger girls i think a lot of them are
really pampered
really yeah i see they're pampered like
entitled
or like hardcore like eldest daughter
you know never had any stability i gotta
be the the man
type thing just because if you haven't
seen it
in your circle or your family doesn't
mean it doesn't exist
just because there aren't really strong
masculine men
in your particular circumstances does
not mean that they don't exist
so that's what i would say don't lose
hope and don't have like this
bad attitude about
men in general just because you had bad
experiences
i know uh
men who have had terrible experiences
with women
because their moms were abusive and
they're
they had a lot of bad female family
members and then they're kind of like
broken in the sense that they can't
trust a woman
uh but i tell them as well the same
advice
just because you had these bad
experiences and you see
seen a certain thing in your environment
don't project that on all women there's
plenty of
good women out there and you know you
should have faith in allah that
you have taqwa and you have sabor and
you put your trust
in allah then he will find you a way out
and he will match you with someone
who is at your level you know in terms
of your
love for allah so always have that in
mind like taweco is so so
important on issues of marriage and
family you can't do it alone you have to
rely on allah that's the only way anyone
is going to survive
okay what about a woman who before we
give advice to men
what about the woman who has that just
like you're saying
she already has a man but the man's not
being a man
so she's now she can't just you know
leave the man maybe she's
tried you know because women aren't over
like us right danny knows this
women are they're gonna sub communicate
that you know you're not being a man but
they'll never tell you
and some men are just so blind and not
present that they
don't they're not aware of that so what
they they these women do is they kind of
feel like okay
he's not listening he's not being a man
so i kind of just by default i got to do
everything right just like
the other two brothers here were saying
before i got to fix everything in the
house i got to do all the manual wait
but they're not doing anything
so what can this woman do
well it depends on exactly the situation
but
um cases that i have experienced or seen
sometimes the woman just thinks that she
has to do everything because she
is like a micro manager and she wants
everything done
her way that's one case and if that's
the case then she just needs to step
back
and like not try to manage everything
let the guy have to step up like he'll
have to step up
there was one case where uh this muslim
couple actually
and the guy was just he wasn't really
you know he was kind of more
intellectual he was maybe a little bit
absent-minded
so he wouldn't pay the bills on time
like they had money
like he had a job uh and she had a job
too actually
so they had money but like paying the
bills on time he would like forget
and so the wife would kind of manage
that
but then she just got frustrated and was
like look i'm not gonna deal with this
anymore
i'm not gonna pay the bills and then
their lights got cut off
like one month and or for at one because
they hadn't paid their bill
and then that was like a wake-up call
for the guy like
wow i i really need to step up because
otherwise we're not gonna have
electricity
when i got water so she so the woman
just had to step
back and that allowed the man to kind of
wake up and realize that this is his job
he has to secure
the house he has to secure the bills and
make sure that everything is
managed and taken care of on that
respect
but then there's other situations where
maybe the man
is not really being manly because you're
not being womanly
like are you sometimes like if you
try to take care of him right and you
like make a real effort to do things
that are specific to your role as a wife
and as a mother then that will inspire
him
and kind of make him wake up that look
there are defined
roles here because a lot of guys
unfortunately you mentioned
at the beginning there there's this
feminization of
of men and they unfortunately
need to be trained and inspired and kind
of shown
and like you guys are trying to do this
with your podcast brother gabrielle is
doing that with his
channels and a lot of guys are now
trying to
teach leadership teach how to be a man
with
muruga and rajula but for a woman who is
in that situation do your part
not by criticizing like because a lot of
men don't react positively to when
they're being criticized
in uh instead like try to inspire
you you know do your specific roles and
you know you're nudging him basically
like look i need a man i need a man in
this situation like you need to pick it
up
and some guys are just lazy and
that's you know the reality it's a sad
reality
but you know for them they they might
need something more like they need their
family to encourage them
like if they have their father right
talk to the like if you're the the wife
talk to your father-in-law and be like
oh did you know that
you know we might need help with this or
maybe the imam at the masjid can help
and talk to the guy like
you your responsibility on xyz
so it's really a case-by-case basis and
there's not going to be one
fit all solution but those are the
things that come to my mind
oh man always such good advice do you
brothers want to put another point or
two before ask the next question
uh yeah on he'll go
you haven't spoken that much so go ahead
okay that's right
i was going to say that was a great
answer my shot i feel like it was it was
very encompassing alhamdulillah
so just i just wanted to to add
again this is what i was saying like it
kind of i feel like it starts with men
the fact that a woman just has to
kind of you know do what she can do but
essentially she's waiting for him to be
a man
it goes back to a man stepping up to be
a man and and this is something we've
lost which is it's
if it's a fundamental crisis within men
that they're not being
men so it's a journey for everyone
everyone has their own journey but
men need to put aside this preconceived
notion that they can't be masculine
and they have to first understand what
masculinity is right
for me it was looking at the prostate
right seeing it in the good man around
me
right for actual practical experience
but um to have the proper understanding
i would go to the prosthetic
and see how he was and i'm not talking
about being what society says
you know a man is he was a super nice
guy who's agreeable
and everyone likes him because he's
super nice i'm talking about being a
good man
with good fundamental morals which goes
back to islam
who can stand up to the plate when he
needs to be he needs to be brave like
the prophet saw was brave and he needs
to actually be a man so forget what you
think you know about being a man
and just relearn what it means to be a
man go to islam go to the apostle i said
i'm see what you know
the best of generations the best of men
see what they were like
and try and incorporate that into your
life and see how it changes
significantly and it may take
three four years right
to see some change but as long as you're
working towards that you'll get there
someday insha'allah but you know this is
an imanna
you know coach rami went in
for that uh yo real quick before ana
says daniel how much more time you got
um i can go for another 10 minutes
perfect all right so before angel goes
one word guys auto deposit
all right if you don't want to be that
husband that has your wife nagging
because you didn't pay those bills on
time set up auto deposit man
the money will get withdrawn when the
bill is due and provided you got money
in the bank that shouldn't be an issue
that's facts um i would just
you know just agree with both around me
and with daniel
um the only thing i would add is like if
if you're a woman oh
this is hard because i mean we're not
women so i can't say much here but if
if i was a woman if i was a woman
uh i would be feminine from the rip
from the start and you'll notice that
most women are feminine from the start
like if you meet them for the first time
they tend to be pretty feminine it's
it's literally you
as a man or he's literally the the male
as a man or whether he is a man or not
that's gonna
cause her to start like shifting to her
masculine it could happen later in the
relationship it could happen
right there in the beginning it's like
bro women respond
off like those uh subtle the subtle
communications
the the body language and uh the shifts
in your your tone while you're speaking
and uh the way your eyes are looking
honestly there's body language too but
you feel what i'm saying and if a woman
responds to that
and she starts acting more masculine
from the rib well the woman should know
like if i'm a woman i would know okay
this is not a
proper man this is not a proper man
and if i'm with him i'm probably not
going to be
happy i'm not going to feel good and bro
as a woman she's going to feel happy and
feel good when she's in her feminine
so if i if i'm a woman and i'm like
internally
have this realization like oh i'm not
gonna be happy am i gonna feel good with
this guy it's because
this guy is not a masculine dude he's
not proper
right but like let's say a girl is in a
relationship after a while
if the guy begins to fall off which
let's be honest a lot of guys fall off
and
they um i don't know they get lazy or
they start becoming feminine or
whatever it is that happens um and the
guy starts to fall off and he he's not
withholding his
side of the bargain you know he's not
being the male the masculine in the
relationship
well it's kind of like how daniel said
like quit trying to control everything
if i was woman
um number one i wouldn't try to control
everything i would just kind of
let it be and number two is i would
actually stop doing the things that are
like
very feminine for him and that would
happen naturally because
think about it if a man is feminine the
woman can't be feminine as well like
there has to be a masculine and a
feminine so it's either going to be the
man and the woman
masculine feminine or the man being
feminine and the woman being masculine
so it's like again as a woman i would
just kind of
chill ease back and not
do so much not just in the sense of like
my duties but also
in the relationship and like in us
talking
and all that stuff where it's like a
guy's gonna notice that real quick
if a girl his girl is not talking yeah
his girl
doesn't wanna uh be affectionate and all
that stuff
are you trying to cut me off bro no i'm
trying to say one word bro
relax yeah relax exactly
the woman just has to relax and if she
chills out relax and backs off like
the guy will be in tune even if he's
been out of tune
he will be in tune with the fact that
you
are probably not cooking him any food
you are not paying him any attention you
are not giving him any affection you're
not being
the feminine and he's gonna react like
i'm sorry but every dude's gonna react
in one way shape or form and he's
he's gonna do something you know so i
mean again
i don't have much insight because i'm
not a woman but i feel like if i was a
woman those are like little things that
i
would pick up on you're out here posting
thirst traps all day wondering why your
husband's just not
not with you not paying you any mind why
would he so
before i ask daniel his last question
and then let you guys
ask him any last questions you have
about just under 10 minutes left
anyone watching this that made it this
far that wants to know how to be a real
man
i think subscribing to this podcast
without tooting our own horn would be
the first
step subscribe to the muslim skeptic as
well brother daniel
and if you want to watch more about
masculinity
watch our episode i think it was 14 with
brother gabriel romani on masculinity
there is no toxic masculinity i think
toxic masculinity is a woman just like
angel said in his videos
and don't listen to society uh let me
finish this point like
saying don't listen to society but a
real man is this
or real man is that society's not going
to tell you how to be a real man
society is going to tell you how to be a
nice boy and
you're going to live your life being a
nice boy and 30
of these nice boys will then wake up and
then become a bad guy
right you all ever watch like marvel
movies where they got they got
superheroes and they got super villains
bro
superheroes are just putting everyone
first just putting everyone's needs
before them
compromising their masculinity and then
you got super villains who are kind of
like
they're red pill but they like get
bitter and they go meg towel
you know and they're like yo screw all
this right i know mohammed job started a
meg tower podcast now
but they kind of get kind of like just
off it yeah
but it's like you guys see those
anti-heroes like venom
or deadpool they're they're not nice
guys like they still do what they want
they're still good though fundamentally
at the end of the day
right they still want the good of the
people but they're not a bad guy like
they're not evil but they're not gonna
put everyone first they're not gonna
just
you know when someone says jump they
don't say how high they're not that guy
that's right but yeah if you made it
this far subscribe man we got 30 percent
of our viewers
that are not subscribed i don't know
what do you have to say to that
to the subscribe thing or other thing
yeah to the subscribe thing bro 30
i think 29.7 because i go over the
analytics right
they're not subscribed um
isn't that a good percentage yeah that's
that's pretty i mean 70 are subscribed
i'm trying to go for 100
that's very high and very optimistic of
you brother
um but i was gonna say the last channel
bro
that you forgot to mention if if dudes
are out here really trying to become
men like proper men dude you all got to
subscribe to apostate prophet bro
i'm i'm just playing huh you'll be he'll
be a real man though he'll be a real man
according to society
all right romney you got anything to say
before us last question uh
no i was just gonna ask do you guys know
what the hero instinct is
have you guys heard of it no instinct
i i remember hearing that um a while ago
on an ad
saying that like if you trigger a man's
hero instinct then you'll like
you'll land him and i want to know if
you guys had any comments on that
no comment with that bro okay
what is it triggering it like how would
you trigger it though
see that's the thing you know these ads
they don't really reveal the secret at
the end and i'm not gonna go
you know dig into that but essentially
was basically like you know every man
wants to be the hero
right and i see this within myself and i
think a lot of people do
everyone wants to be the hero so if you
make a man feel like he's a hero he's
gonna
he's gonna adore you a lot more because
of the way you make him feel
so i feel like that may be in tune with
a woman being feminine because if a man
knows that you know
he has a feminine woman she's being
feminine with him it's going to make him
feel more like a man or more like the
the one the hero the whatever so yeah i
want to know if you guys had any like
thoughts
yeah bro yo i've been that guy it's not
just it's not just something in your
head i'm sure i know i can relate
bro haven't you been with girls in the
past where it's like every time
something happens you're like babe
what's wrong
like you want to be that guy that like
fixes everything you feel me
you just can't let things be all right
and uh my last question before these two
jump in
real quick is to brother daniel
you talked about women you talked about
men but i feel like you wouldn't have
men and women without parents
so what is your number one advice to
parents
you can give me general advice you can
give me one towards let's say raising
boys and raising girls
but just your two cents inshallah
oh about just raising children in
general yeah
i would say just be it
there is definitely the aspect of being
a good parent but also just being a good
husband like if you're a father be a
good husband
because your children are going to look
up to you
and they're going to respect you more
and they're going to love you more and
you're going to be a good
role model for them if you are a good
husband like how you treat your wife and
if you're
not responsible if you're not stepping
up to be the man then they're not going
to respect you and their
their development is going to be
negatively impacted by
the way that you're shirking your
responsibilities
as a husband and similarly if you're a
mother and you're a wife be the best
wife that you can be because again your
daughters
and your sons are going to look up to
you and see how you treat
their father and it makes a world of a
difference
um because just because you are a parent
now
that doesn't mean you stop being a
husband or you stop being a wife no you
still are a husband and wife and you
have
responsibilities you can't just focus
100 on the kids
and ignore your spouse no do
continue to be the loving caring
responsible
romantic husband romantic wife
and your kids will greatly benefit
uh from that investment that you make in
your spouse it pays off
off major dividends because when parents
are happy
and your parents and children see that
their parents love each other and care
about each other
they just feel so much better and secure
and comfortable
but if their parents are fighting and
arguing
and the marriage is kind of on the rocks
then they
that psychologically affect them and
they're gonna be much more
uh anxious uneasy because it's an
unstable situation
so this is in line with islam like the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that the best of
you are the ones who are best
to your families the best of you are the
best and another
narration the best of you are the ones
who are the best to their women folk
so we have to be our best uh
to our spouses and that will
trickle down and influence our children
as well
great answer you all got any questions
i asked mine earlier on hill what your
last name is
how do you pronounce how do you say it
one more time
i'm not trying to try you bro but um i
heard that
apus said that your last name sounded
like pikachu
he thinks that like that's a big insult
but i think he gets more pissed off when
people call him apus
you know been funny if while you guys
were having this uh
debate he would have pulled that out and
you just would have busted out like a
pikachu pokemon card
like yeah it was good yeah like that's
fine i know it's a hard name to
pronounce that's okay
it's cool though i like i like it
so guys with that being said hold on
yeah
if y'all made it this far go ahead and
put
hashtag man up
and i'll let y'all finish it yeah man
you know what's crazy i was literally
gonna say hashtag man up
for real no no that's what i was gonna
say and then you were like hold up hold
up and then you just said then i was
like
that's my man bro all right so now you
guys have to type that i take man up
and subscribe subscribe to us subscribe
to brother angel's shell
angel as you see his name is pronounced
or spelled right there but with two a's
and subscribe to the brother daniel
akika that's how i pronounce it bro
don't take any offense
um known as the muslim skeptic
always posting real content not the most
politically correct not
not gonna agree with your reality but it
aligns with
the reality and of course find
us on ig and brother rami has a book as
well that i want to shout out bro
it's called the ambidextrous really good
book man really good book
a lot of poems in there i recommend
y'all get it
with brother poet rami and he has a tic
tac too
but with that being said subscribe to
the video like this video get these
likes up too
and if you want to get brother daniel
back on this podcast
in the near future don't just write
hashtag man up
write hashtag man up and also write
hashtag bring daniel back
and with that being said rami ended off
bless you all and our our honorable
guest here masha allah brother daniel
thank you for for coming on the show
mashallah it's always a pleasure and we
look forward to having you in the future
insha'allah
that being said may allah
you do this and like your foreplay could
literally consist of nothing but that
y'all could not even have sex and she
would literally
submit to you in every single way even
after the fact
and i i speak that from experience
but um for a lot of purposes if you do
that with your wife
you will see crazy things and if you're
a woman watching this throw this over to
your husband so he can
learn the game if you're doing it
properly and stuff where she
climaxes even if it's just minor ones
multiple times before you even actually
start
you know having the real intercourse and
when you get to that point you know
you're doing it right
what i wanted to add about this whole
foreplay thing
is that a woman has
three stages of orgasm
have an orgasm stage one
all right stage two is orgasm from
penetration or orgasm from
your finger penetrating and hitting the
g-spot
that's like three four or five times
before
penetrating like you really don't have
to go fast at all
you could keep it super slow and just do
exactly what fire was uh showing there
and like you'll probably have a bust
another few times before it's your time
yeah if if you're okay that your beliefs
and your sex life are both in line and
they're both good
you're gonna be fine and that's the kind
of the fundamental the the basis of it
right in that connection
you have the actual you know emotional
connection with your beliefs and
everything being in line you have the
sexual connection with
which is the intimacy being aligned both
are necessary you need them um so focus
on that
and just think about how many things you
didn't know that we just talked about
now
right and i'll think about how much more
there is that you probably don't know
because you grew up in a society where
they don't talk about these things and
they're shunned
they shouldn't be shunned because if
they're shuns then you won't have good
intimacy then your marriage breaks apart
then your family breaks up the community
breaks apart
it's not good it starts here and with
that being said
may allah bless you all and grant us
good spouses and children who will be
the coolness of our eyes and allow us to
be leaders for the righteous people
[Music]
one one of the wiser profit i said um
she you know was laying with him
and then she you know her period hit and
she had to go
kind of sneak out of bed to go get
cleaned up and stuff and the prosthetist
said i'm noticed that she was kind of
subtly sneaking away
and um he said when you you know when
you when you're finished when you
come back and and come back close to me
come even closer to me
because in that state she may feel a bit
impure like maybe i shouldn't be close
to him
also i said him he knew that he sensed
it from her and he's like when you're
done
come back and get even closer to me to
make her feel you know
loved and appreciated small things like
that that go
you know the extra mile jordan peterson
talks a lot about people need such
little motivation in life they need such
little motivation
and if you can't even give that how are
you going to call yourself a leader
let alone a man right and another
example i want to give
is you know the one we all know when the
prosthetic side was eating with aisha
and she would drink from the cup he
would turn it to drink from the same
spot
right this is not a word he didn't have
to say anything he just did something
subtle
but obviously it filled her it filled
her heart with love
a more uh critical example would be
when uh a woman her son died and the
cross said i said
i forgot what he said but he went up to
her when she was crying at his grave
and he said something sorry to him and
she yelled at the prophet
there are ayat in the quran saying don't
raise your voice of the prophet sam
right
and the prophet saw he didn't pull this
out and say you don't yell at me i'm the
prophet right
he walked away he knew this is not the
time
and he walked away and as a man we need
to know sometimes we want to walk
away another big thing but this this
just shows how deep
this entire um practice is
so once you understand emotional
intelligence as
a general you know mechanism or uh
general concept and you understand the
four things that i mentioned
um then once you have these mechanisms
down you'll you'll operate a lot better
in life
[Music]
[Music]
um